back on the streets
defying a curfew in myanmar this protest
against the military began like others
with people marching in the streets of
michinar
but moments later
at least three people were shot dead by
security forces
witnesses say several people were then
hit by gunfire from nearby buildings
it's part of an ongoing crackdown on
those who oppose the military's recent
coup
kneeling before security forces this
catholic nun
pleads with them to stop the violence
the government has revoked the license
of at least five independent media
outlets that were covering the protests
large-scale demonstrations have taken
place every day across many cities and
towns in myanmar
but these demonstrations come at a risk
i want to speak out and i want us to
stop being afraid i want women to join
and save this movement
by protesting alongside men against the
military dictatorship
[Music]
dozens of protesters have been killed
the united nations fears
more deaths will follow
signs of resistance have followed
despite arrests and violence
hanging women's clothes across the
streets of myanmar may be one of the
most creative lines of defense
walking beneath female clothes is
traditionally considered bad luck for
men
and many soldiers are avoiding crossing
the line
as a woman from myanmar this is
motivating me these garments are
considered sacred so we're using the
superstition to fight back against the
military
the military denies responsibility for
protesters loss
of life it claims toppled leader on
sansuchi deserved to be pushed out last
month
she was elected it says amid widespread
electoral fraud
but thousands of protesters disagree
and say the public outcry will continue
katya lopez al jazeera